oh my god are you tom brady
no tom brody
who's that and that's me
hi i'm tom brady and i'm a crybaby and i
have a butthole in my chin
butthole tom brady could have made
probably the same amount of money
as a male prostitute trust me i'm good
at math
i hate tom brady so much but i have no
legit reason to he's a nice guy
but i hope they break his leg
[Laughter]
tom brady was listed ahead of his wife
gisele bundchen and
forbes recent list of the 100 most
powerful celebrities
but last year tom was behind his wife
when asked to comment brady said hey
we switch positions all the time if you
know what i'm saying
and then he high-fived the reporter
you tom brady i hope your dog eats
chocolate and gets really sick and
throws up on your socks
so here's my tom brady story i was there
the day that gisele met tom brady no way
i was at the game she came to the
chargers game in uh san diego and i sat
i sit with the craft family and i'm
talking to her and
i'm helping her she didn't really know
she was like what is the football she
was like
i was walking her through it and then i
got to see them meet
i was there we went down to the locker
room and i'm telling you she's beautiful
but then he's beautiful and when they
got together we all just felt
so ugly at that moment they were like
white walkers they just drained us of
all our our life energy and beauty is
michael jordan officially the second
best athlete of all time
that is the discussion yes you think yes
100
on this indisputable okay now why give
me give me why
i mean look what tom brady did can you
imagine michael jordan going to a second
team
and winning a championship i think he
didn't even get to the playoffs yeah
when 75 of your conference gets to the
playoffs but
mg was 40 years old i know i know he
can't do anything he's going to do it
every 40. how could he possibly compete
with all these young bucks who are so
athletic and brilliant the game has to
completely change how could he compete
with them at 40.
yep i mean how old was tom oh tommy 43
oh he was older much
older interesting okay okay okay three
years big difference
people make a big deal about i was
talking to somebody's in the group chat
and they also brought up the different
team thing i don't think people realize
how difficult it is to win with another
team
it's incredibly hard also but why break
it down why
you're going to a different system yes
you are he's going to a different
conference so he's playing
different teams pretty much all together
every team he sees is different if
you're on the same team
you play almost half your schedule every
year against the same division opponents
right he knows the buffalo bills inside
and out now he's playing the saints
twice
and he got curb stomped twice and then
in the playoffs he was like no i got it
now
it's it's good now right right now he's
going to completely new personnel
completely new culture completely new
city yeah everything is different yeah
everything is different yeah but here's
what tom brady is tom brady
is you know people that say like it's a
vibe tom brady is a culture
i think that we don't know a lot about
tom brady which i also like
i think that's cool there's some mystery
to him he's a throwback he's marlon
brando
yeah you know what i mean he's one of
these figures that
we get what he decides to give us yeah
he's got a sense of humor clearly
like on his instagram he's aware of the
things that he's posting are funny
he's kind of culturally aware yep like
if you notice like even the music that
he chooses
in the videos it's all hip-hop yeah does
everything sit right like he's going for
it like this is supposed to be megatom
brady he's not doing a luke bryant
no whatever these [ __ ] country guys
are what's what's your boy
who was dropping them bombs oh my god
morgan whalen my god he's not morgan way
alone you know i mean you're a boy
bro he's one of you in the neighborhood
he might drop a couple of them
the coolest i would ever feel so
while we'll never know if tom brady
could impact the game in the same way
that michael jordan could impact the
game
because they don't the sports don't
compare in that way
we do know that he was able to motivate
more people yes to greatness than jordan
was yes
[Music]
and i am just smiling ear to ear
smiling ear to ear i can't remember the
last time
i was just happy i just
what what a sunday i just had
i gotta tell you man i've never been so
wrong in my life
a lot of you guys probably think that
i'm going to gloat i was so wrong
about the balance bike you know i took
my daughter
out to the park and i figured it out
finally you got to like you got to take
them after they kind of
they get bored with it when they're on
like the level what am i talking about
here
tom brady won his seventh [ __ ] super
bowl
wow brady the gronk twice whoa
leonard fournette running that [ __ ]
ball just like i said
just like i [ __ ] said oh
i try to be humble people i can't on
this one i told you [ __ ] since
back in november
how beatable a team like kansas city was
i told you i [ __ ] told you bill
belichick coaches the cleveland browns
they win that [ __ ] game
they just didn't stick with their game
plan to run that's what you do
it's what you do it's what the [ __ ] i
said oh
god damn it i feel good
sorry tom brady seven rings
seven rings he's one behind belichick
now for all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
had a buddy of mine just going oh bill
belichick's probably drinking gasoline
right now bill belichick has eight rings
okay tom brady just passed michael
jordan it's un
[ __ ] believe i've never been i was
rooting for tampa bay
in that game it was like the patriots
were playing that's how much i gave a
[ __ ] i couldn't believe it
i was actually upset with myself and
when they went for it
for that [ __ ] touch when they went
for it on fourth and goal in the second
quarter i
i might my family had to leave the room
i was like what are they doing what are
they doing what are they doing they
don't get it
why would you do that
i just realized that's the wahlberg line
when when his mother's tearing down his
posters and boogie nights
don't do it why would you do that stop
it that's literally i bitched about
them having three points in their back
pocket in a [ __ ] championship game
and not kicking that field goal i
bitched about that until about eight
minutes left in the fourth quarter
that's when i could finally relax
because that's how good
kansas city's offense is um but i gotta
tell you two
a [ __ ] t two a [ __ ] t
they did exactly what the [ __ ] a
stand-up comedian said they were gonna
do that's not bad come on people you
gotta give it up okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna gloat on this one
double tyrique let [ __ ] kelsey beat
you underneath he's going to get a bunch
of yards but he's not going to get it
all on one [ __ ] play
the need of kansas city comes out and
scores quick you don't you don't lose
your composure stick with the [ __ ]
run
wear down their [ __ ] defensive line
you're going to be running downhill
getting first downs chewing up clock
in the second [ __ ] half it's exactly
exactly what the [ __ ] happened
oh oh freckles want some [ __ ] money
on that super bowl
i bet the coin toss heads oh [ __ ] i
missed the gatorade i said blue gatorade
i think i lost on that one
um i didn't go red it just seemed too
obvious both teams had red you know
and i don't i know that gatorade didn't
make pewter and the blue i always
thought tasted pretty good or the lime i
should have gone with the lemon lime
i don't even know what i mean maybe i
won i have no idea i didn't even look i
was just so
[ __ ] excited in seeing brady de gronk
for two touchdowns and then antonio
brown
who patriots nation still loves
even though he you got that victory
against the dolphins
uh you know in 2019 or whatever
um i don't know every all my pat's
friends that are all pat's fans are
going [ __ ] nuts we're all so happy
for the guy
so don't believe any of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i saw in the nfl network or
some crap they were like how do patriots
fans feel and these [ __ ] [ __ ]
already had their minds made up of how
pats fans felt
so they had to look and sift and sift
until they find six [ __ ]
jerk-offs that will say what they wanted
them to say
you should have seen these pats fans
they look like they went to like [ __ ]
the patriots pro shop they had so much
pat's gear on i'm calling [ __ ]
honestly well it's like if your
girlfriend broke up with you then she
invite you to the wedding
nobody says that nobody said that but
you know they went out and they
the same way anytime back in the day
when they would show a patriots game
they used to [ __ ]
they go down to the beach and they'd
show like a lighthouse like i
can't i can tell you dude
my 27 years i lived in massachusetts the
only lighthouse i ever saw was when i
came back four years later and they
built a fake one at gillette stadium
making us all out to be lobster
fishermen and tying sailor nuts and
eating clam chowder whatever the [ __ ] it
is was you know like everybody in new
york is going
hey i'm walking here i'm holding a hero
you know and everybody in philly all
they do every day is just stand in line
for a steak and cheese it's so [ __ ]
stupid but that's what they do
anyway um i'm all over the map here i am
so
[ __ ] happy for tom brady gronk tampa
the fans of tampa
that was just i mean jesus christ
the amount of brady bashers throughout
the guy's [ __ ] career i've
just never seen anything like it um
and this is the one i think that he
needed that will just finally even shut
jim irsay up i think what's what the
[ __ ] are they gonna say now
the guy beat drew brees in new orleans
aaron rodgers and the packers
in [ __ ] lambo
and then he beat the uh the next
greatest quarterback ever uh patrick
mahomes
[ __ ] unbelievable unbelievable
reminds me of when eli and the giants
beat the patriots
undefeated patriots they beat dallas in
dallas
they beat some of the wild card team i
think and they beat somebody else
i think the cowboys in dallas
and then they beat the undefeated page
just as far as undeniable championships
i put it up with those uh
2008 giants and i never thought the 2008
giants got their
due because it wasn't that they won it
was that the patriots lost because they
were undefeated
and i really feel if we had one loss and
went in there
um they would have got the respect they
deserved and god knows eli
never did with the [ __ ] new york
media they used to talk about that guy
you know right to the end of his career
like he never he never won anything
i don't know it's weird so weird uh
the uh east coast media is uh brutal
it's [ __ ] brutal boston is just as
brutal at least it was when i was there
so
um god damn what a [ __ ] game just to
watch them
execute it so [ __ ] perfectly i mean
the whole patron of homes to no
touchdowns
no touchdown uh passes
i mean he had like a hundred yards in
the first half it was just
textbook textbook textbook textbook
okay so there you go all you young
football fans remember
this super bowl okay i'm not taking
anything away from the chiefs but i'm
telling you
when you have an unbelievable offense
but only a
decent defense you
are you are beatable and the deeper you
go into the playoffs the more beatable
you are because the better the team
you play week after week after week
and they finally you know everybody
knows how to beat them they just
the afc just does not have a [ __ ]
team either with experience
cleveland is the [ __ ] team um
with the right coaching and a little
more experience can match up with the
team like that and as i said i saw the
[ __ ]
you just saw tampa bay beat kansas city
you saw the giants beat the undefeated
patriots
in 2008 or whatever the [ __ ] it was 2001
you saw the patriots beat the greatest
show on turf
you saw the dirty birds beat the 15-1
vikings [ __ ] randall cunningham and
randy moss
looking like juggernauts went into their
own building and beat him
all the way back all the way back
running gun bills
giants beat him [ __ ] elway with all
his [ __ ]
receivers giants shut them down
the next year the redskins shut them
down i've just seen it time
and time again i saw the 49ers shut down
dan marino 48
touchdown passes back when that [ __ ]
meant something at 5 000 yards
they came out in 84 and beat him um
i saw the raiders come and beat the
redskins
he's just seen it time and time again a
defense
what's a running game shuts they just
have him sitting on the sidelines like
[ __ ] bernie sanders
at the inauguration um all right i am
done gloating
okay i was so [ __ ] right about that
game
and i got the money in my pocket
tomorrow to prove it i never talk [ __ ]
but here's the balance
which i was trying to do i was trying to
come on this podcast and be humble i
really was
but i was just so [ __ ] excited i mean
the game literally just ended
15 minutes ago